in late March a Navajo tribal member
learned she had been exposed to
coronavirus and sucked testing at an
Indian Health Service or IHS hospital
they were me away and told me that I
didn't have any symptoms that night
around midnight I started to run fevers
and the next day the body aches started
they were so excruciating like every
bone in my body was hurting all the way
down to the tip of my toes to the tip of
my fingers with very very bad headaches
Farah Begay returned to the IHS hospital
but they refused to admit her or her 66
year old mother who was also ill they
turned us away and told us that come
back until it gets worse and you know at
that point you're like what is worse me
what's worse than this it's gonna get
worse than this the IHS is run by the
federal government in Washington it is
notoriously underfunded understaffed and
under equipped we asked the IHS
repeatedly over several weeks for an
interview but got nowhere we don't have
the best health care system on a Navajo
Nation we have been hit hard by this
virus that has snuck into our
communities here on the Navajo Nation
Navajo lands are impoverished rural and
arid basic infrastructure is shockingly
bad you know you got the CDC saying wash
your hands with soap and water everybody
but you know what 30% of our Navajo
people do not have running water
he says Native American communities
aren't getting the emergency money they
need for testing and equipment we're
just kidding just little bits of funding
to our nation's and that's all the all
the tribes throughout the country it
just seems like the first citizens of
this country have been ignored
once again on
fourth visit to the IHS barely able to
breathe Begay pleaded desperately for
help we're already feeling pain and fear
so when is worse gonna be worse until
we're dead she and her mother were
finally taken to better equipped
hospitals in Arizona after weeks they
have now recovered but many Navajo have
not I've known people personally from
this community that were turned away
like that went home and died in their
own homes the first Americans once again
last in line for help
Rob Reynolds al-jazeera